the three engines of growth are ways to
think about customer acquisition the
first one is the sticky engine of growth
where you're gonna focus on bringing
your customers back month after month
you really want them to stick with you
you're really focusing here on keeping
customers with you rather than acquiring
new customers so this is the right
engine to focus on if you're focused on
retaining customers for the long term
the second engine of growth is the viral
engine this is usually heaven for
entrepreneurs where they get to the
point where their customers are bringing
in new customers and a user base is just
growing virally and organically now I
wouldn't rely on this one because it's
really hard to actually get here your
products is gonna have to be incredible
and really fit your target market
perfectly otherwise it doesn't really
work so once you have a really awesome
product growth can be self-sustaining
but it doesn't necessarily happen to
everyone and the third engine of growth
is the paid engine of growth most
startups have to be familiar with this
one and most advertising channels fall
into this engine now as long as you're
making a profit on each customer you can
keep operating this engine your profit
will allow you to invest more and more
into advertising and help you sustain
your growth now big companies will focus
on more than one or even all of these
engines however as a start-up we
recommend that you focus on only one at
a time in this lesson in particular
we'll be focusing on the paid engine for
customer acquisition if you're
interested in learning more we highly
recommend checking out the book the lean
startup it describes these three engines
as part of a whole Lean Startup approach
that helps entrepreneurs build fast
growing companies and encourages them to
build measure and learn on an ongoing
basis check out the link to the book in
the instructor notes
ok so let's dive into this paid engine
of growth